at this altitude I can run my hands
[Music]
this episode is brought to you by ring
rings mission is to make neighborhoods
safer you might already know about their
smart video doorbells and cameras that
protect millions of people everywhere
ring helps you to stay connected to your
home from anywhere in the world very
important for me given how much I travel
and bounce around so if there's a
package delivery or a surprise visitor
good or bad
you'll get an alert and be able to see
hear and speak to whoever is at your
door all from your phone I've personally
used ring for years now I've known about
rang from day one actually and tried
early prototypes and throughout so I've
been a user for a long time it catches
and records all the regular stuff like
deliveries and so on but it's also saved
my ass quite a few times
catching weirdos and weird things so
ring is key to my peace of mind and as a
listener of the Tim Ferriss show you
have a special offer on a ring welcome
kit available right now at ring.com
slash Tim tea I am the kit includes a
video doorbell and a chime Pro which are
just what you need to start building a
ring of security around your home today
so check it out go to ring.com slash tim
to take advantage of this offer today or
just to learn a little bit more check
out the details at ring.com slash tim
this offer is for US residents only
this episode is brought to you by helix
sleep last year I focused on
dramatically improving a few things
surprise surprise most notably the
quality of my sleep which seems to
affect just about everything this led me
to revisit you name it my daily routine
morning routine exercise diet all the
way to what I slept on and I ended up
getting all new beds here in Austin
Texas including mattresses from helix
sleep helix has built a sleep quiz that
takes two minutes to complete and they
use the answers to match your body type
and sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress whether you're a side sleeper
hot sleeper cold sleeper or you like
plush you like firm with helix there's
no more guessing or confusion just go to
helix sleep calm forward-slash Tim take
their two minutes sleep quiz and they'll
match you to a mattress that will give
you the best sleep of your life that is
their promise for couples helix can even
split the mattress down the middle
providing individual support needs and
feel preferences for each side they have
a 10 year warranty and you can test
drive your mattress for a 100 nights
risk-free right now helix is offering up
to 125 dollars off of all mattress
orders so check it out get up to 125 off
at helix sleep comm forward slash Tim
that's helix sleep dot-com for slash Tim
for 125 dollars off your mattress order
take a look helix sleep comm forward
slash Tim
why hello boys and girls ladies and
germs this is Tim Ferriss welcome to
another episode of the Tim Ferriss show
where it is my job to sit down with
world-class performers of all different
types and this is going to be a
different one to tease out the mental
models favorite books and so on that you
can test and apply in your own life this
episode features the amazing Marcella
otha Laura ot ' a lor a you might not
recognize that name but you'll get her
bio after this intro and understand
exactly why I so wanted to sit down with
her this interview was recorded live at
the psychedelic science summit here in
Austin Texas which you can learn more
about at psychedelic science org it was
organized by maps all caps M ApS
standing for the multidisciplinary
Association for psychedelic studies and
featured presentations from founder of
maps Rick Doblin mycologist Paul Stamets
addiction expert dr. Carl Hart and many
many more you can learn more about maps
and their training for aspiring
psychedelic therapists that is
above-ground legal psychedelic therapist
at maps org forward slash training also
we compiled extensive resources for this
episode and to make them easily
accessible links to everything
further reading next possible steps etc
you can go to tim dot blog slash
therapist and it will take you straight
to where you want to go so tim dog
forward slash their epistle take you
directly to the blog post for this
podcast episode and you can scroll down
to the show notes for links to
everything that we mentioned and
everything you could possibly want so be
sure to check that out tim dot blog
forward slash therapist there were a few
small glitches in my audio at the very
beginning of the interview but my
microphone was very quickly replaced so
thank you for your patience for the
first few minutes it's intelligible and
it improves after the first few minutes
so all that said without further ado
please enjoy this wide-ranging interview
with Marcela da da da
I'm so excited about this interview I
know a lot of you are too Tim Ferriss
and Marcella otah Laura who is a Maps
person Tim Ferriss is a supporter of
maps and a psychedelic and the
psychedelic research and shifting the
beliefs about psychedelic medicine in
our culture and for that we are very
grateful he has been called a cross
between Jack Welsh and a Buddhist monk
by the New York Times he is one of past
company's most innovative businesspeople
and an early-stage tech investor he is
the author of five number one New York
Times and Wall Street Journal
bestsellers including the 4-hour
workweek The Observer and other media
have named him the Oprah of audio due to
the influence of his podcast the Tim
Ferriss show which has exceeded 400
million downloads his latest book is
tribe of mentors short life advice from
the best in the world and he is one of
the world's most popular podcasters we
are so thrilled to have him Marcella is
a psychotherapist and an installation
artist her interest and focus on trauma
has led her to understand the healing
process as an intimate reconnection with
one's essence through love integrity
acceptance and honoring of the human
spirit in addition to working with
trauma and PTSD she has dedicated her
professional life to teaching and
research she uses art as a vehicle for
deepening the relationship to self
others and the natural world Marcella
worked as a co therapist in maps very
first government-regulated mdma-assisted
psychotherapy study in Madrid Spain and
she has served as the principal
investigator for maps phase two
mdma-assisted psychotherapy study in
boulder colorado and currently in the
MDMA healthy volunteer study and phase 3
site also in Colorado additionally she
is a trainer and supervisor for
therapists working on map studies for
mdma-assisted psychotherapy I would say
one of the things that I think of when I
think of Marcela is if there was one
person that I would want to put
my future training in the hands of or my
psyche or my soul in the hands of she
would certainly be maybe one of the top
two people in the world so I have great
respect for the work that she does on
behalf of maps please welcome Tim and
Marcela
to the stage to discuss Marcela's work
as a psychedelic therapist and maps
therapist trainer thank you
which good day everyone thank you for
coming this is the third participant
Molly the dog not named after any
particular molecules and this session we
have lots of time for we have 90 minutes
it is a good stretch we may not go that
long we will see we're gonna surf the
waves and I'm thrilled to be here after
that intro please give me time to
disappoint it's all downhill after that
bio I'm very good at writing them in
third person and I really just want to
jump in while you're gonna sit at sentry
duty
Aaron les thanks for this topic I think
is a good idea and Marcella I think we
could just start at the beginning if you
could tell us a little bit about where
you're from where you grew up just to
give us a little bit of context sure I
grew up I was born and Columbia and I
was raised there I came to the state's
when I was 20 mm-hmm and when you were
in your childhood or early teens you can
pick what did you think you want it to
be when you grew up or what you would be
this is kind of like a edgy story
because what I wanted to be was a fire
truck going to be a fire truck yeah I
wanted to be a fire truck Wow
that that's incredible I think we should
dig into this so this was not an
enhanced vision of what you wanted to be
this was this was this was a decision
you can't do as a little girl how did
you decide on fire truck what was the
appeal of the fire truck shiny and red
and they had ladders and hoses
all true usually like dogs yeah the team
and you could and it was just like you
could you could literally block a road
like you had that much power like you
could just walk around and you know what
was interesting is that a lot of people
when I told them that they would say do
you mean a fire person I said no a fire
truck and everybody thought it was
either like oh poor thing you know like
oh my god okay or like I hope somebody
tells her or something like that but my
mother worked at the mental health
hospital and I used to love going there
and playing cards with all the inmates
it was something that I really where I
felt safe actually and so there was this
man his nickname was force for Itoh
which means a little match he was a para
maniac and he asked me what I wanted to
be when I grew up and I told them and he
was the first person ever who said wow
do you mean like one of those red fire
phosphor Ito got it yeah he totally got
it why did you feel safe in that
environment why do you feel comfortable
in that environment in the hospital well
and how old were you roughly when I
decided to be a fire know when you when
you were playing cards with us yeah I I
started maybe when I was around 12 and I
it's kind of like what I asked for my
birthday every year to go spend time
there and play cards and talk to people
and I think it was where I felt seen I
think I was I came you know I grew up in
a country where civil wars started when
I was born practically and it wasn't
safe and I saw a lot of things happen
because
of the war on drugs and just a danger of
the city where I grew up and my family
of origin wasn't safe there was a lot of
abuse and so it was like I could be with
people who didn't care about that yeah
there's a I suppose of purity in a way
yeah good insulation yeah so the the
feeling scene I think will probably be a
perhaps a theme that carries through the
conversation but if we flash-forward
where did interest in psychedelic
therapy or exposure to that begin how
did you end up finding your way to that
subject or path so I I ran away from
home when I was 17 and ended up in the
streets and I was homeless for a while
which was probably one of the hardest
experiences I ended up with like the
wrong crowd after that and spent a year
in a really abusive situation and then I
decided to kind of like find a way to
escape so so my escape was to come to
the United States I had been here when I
was 12 and I loved it it was one of
those experiences where you know like
when you when you have all this
expectations of a place and you think
what's gonna look like this or is gonna
be like this and it never quite matches
well it matched and it was when reading
Dick and Jane books you're too young for
it no I remember taking joy it was like
Dick and Jane and spot yeah I just it
made me want to come to the States they
had like back doors where you didn't
have to lock it and they had can't
cookie jars and it was great and so it
just matched the town that I ended up in
where were you where in the u.s. in
Boston Boston a little while
outside of Boston so I really wanted to
come back and I came back it was really
hard I was alone didn't have money
didn't you know had this little
scholarship to go to college and so I
started I think part of it was that I
thought if I left the traumas would go
away like that I somehow would surpass
it and if I could forget about it it
would be gone and so I think that was my
my thinking and of course that doesn't
happen and I lived six years with a lot
very restricted life didn't really talk
to people it was just really difficult
and my world was pretty small and then I
had never done any kind of drug ever I
had not even smoked pot and I took him
DMA recreationally for the first time
and what I did was it brought back
everything and it was I wasn't ready for
that I thought it was just going to be
oh this is gonna be something great it's
gonna feel good you're gonna feel good
and it was the opposite it was really
challenging and I was not in a safe
environment I wasn't with people who
could really hold that who could
understand that and it was more like
fear oh no what is happening to this
person and so I knew that like I knew
that it wasn't safe so it made it worse
and I ended up in the hospital and then
a friend ended up in the hospital
because you're the people around you
thought you're having a panic attack or
self-administered yes so then a mutual
friend of Rick's and I asked Rick if he
would do MDMA with me and I think what
it was who was that even though it was a
really traumatic experience I also knew
that there was something really powerful
about the fact that
I couldn't lie anymore so it's a dog it
had unlocked all of that yeah so so I
did MDMA with Rick and a couple of other
people and they held the container and
it was like I saw myself for the first
time the self that you had lost yeah
what did what did Rick or other people
involved and it doesn't have to be exact
phrasing but say to you or do to make
you feel comfortable going back into
that experience what was the lead-up as
opposed to the session what did that
look like it was about totally being
okay with whatever came up like I
couldn't do it wrong you know and I
think you know you said that to me in
the green room you're like you can't do
this wrong and it was like so helpful
it's okay to be you right no it's okay
to mean what you are and so I thought
that and and it was like wow there is
this person that has rights I felt like
all my rights had been taken away so I
had rights for the first time in my life
like I had an inkling of it that I had
rights and that I mattered and that
there was somebody in there that
actually didn't have drama
somewhere in there so you have this
experience what happens in the days and
weeks after that experience that's a
good question I think I did it three
times maybe two within the course of a
month or two I was very fortunate
because I was able to stay in Rick's
house so I it was sort of like a
secluded place for me to be before I had
to return to my life
and I was able I read a lot I wrote a
lot and I read and I tried to capture
what had happened sort of like this idea
of a lack of self-consciousness that had
happened and I think up to that point my
self-consciousness was all about fear
and not belonging and here was like how
like there is this like lack of
self-consciousness like it's it's okay
it's okay if you cry it's okay if you
laugh it's okay and I think that we
provided that too
like I could be alone I could dance
around I could eat I couldn't not eat I
could just be so it allowed me to just
begin a process of of understanding what
was going on and I think some of what
was going on was that I looked at that
for the first time I could look at it I
wasn't looking at trying to make sense
of the trauma I was my symptoms were
completely appropriate for what had
happened in my life it wasn't crazy
it was completely appropriate and I you
know I gave me freedom it gave me
freedom to explore some other things and
to things like well maybe I do have a
say in how I live my life and and I
started you know I started trying like
little things of testing that while I
was in those in those days afterwards so
I started this a day without learning
like I wanted a whole day without
learning anything could I do that and a
day when I said no to everything so
testing this ability to have some say
about my life so that was what it was
either like you know the days after that
what did the space look like or
journey as buzz from that personal
experience to wanting to be more
involved as a facilitator or a therapist
I think because of my own suffering and
having had quite a bit of therapy before
then I I did have therapy before that
experience and it just didn't work that
much
it wasn't very helpful I had a diagnosis
of schizophrenia that was like the first
diagnosis I had and I think it was you
know that I realized that so many people
could not understand trauma could not
understand like the symptoms of trauma
so I thought like wow like it actually
saved my life you know I felt like it
was just something that was giving me
this opportunity and I was a teacher at
the time and I just thought like I
really want to do this I want to do this
for other people I want to be able to
help other people
Rick started Maps a couple of years
after that so he and I he did our work
the year before
MDMA was criminalized in 1984 I was 25
26 and so I thought we're really far
away from that like I I couldn't imagine
that it would ever happen that you could
be that there was a potential of being a
psychedelic psychotherapist but I was
determined that I wanted to work towards
that and it took me a few years I went
to graduate school for art and taught
some more and then went back to school
so that I could become a psychotherapist
and be ready here you're paddling for
the Waverly and you've done so much good
work and helped so many people
who are some of the influences outside
or what are some of the influences
outside of Rick who have shaped how
you've approached becoming the therapist
you are today
mmm cloudy or Naranjo who died recently
he was definitely I was I've resonated a
lot with the way he did the work and so
he was one of my heroes and I I tend to
look for books and writings not through
psychotherapy so much I read those
sometimes but they feel like work and so
I think a lot of the inspiration comes
from arhuaco Indians in the mountains of
Colombia the way that they approach life
through psychedelics and their healing
the way they heal so their stories are
very powerful to me I lived very close
to them for a year before I came to the
States and I read a lot about artists so
there's different artists that have
written about how to be an artist and I
think what it is is that they're very
genuine and they talk about themselves
in a way of this is where I come from
this is the struggles that I've had as
an artist this is where I go and and so
it's so important to do this work
I think Agnes Martin is one of my
favorite artists and she wrote
extensively about how she came to her
work and she was very private an
introvert I tend to be the same way so
there was a lot of things that resonated
with me about her and you know she had
this idea that about perfection that was
really beautiful like she said you know
perfection doesn't exist in the world
but the reason why we're so attached to
it is because we can imagine it and so
those kinds of information are really
great for when you work with somebody
with trauma so I would say that that has
influenced me the most and for those
people who are here or listening who
don't recognize Claudia's name
there's a fantastic books either the
healing journey or a healing journey
about much of his work which is very
well written I mean the introduction
alone is worth the price of admission
with the book and on the I'd never
thought of it quite this way before but
as you're talking about art it it really
made me think I've been taking art
classes for the last few months right
and mostly drawing charcoal working with
pastels different types of different
types of tools with the ultimate goal of
getting to at least as the next step
painting and working with color but the
point that was made to me over and over
again by my teacher is in effect you're
not learning to draw you learning to see
you have to learn to see at first and
you need to draw what you see and not
what you know because you might look at
a chair and then look down at your paper
and draw your concept of a chair but
you've stopped seeing and I can see how
that could apply to listening and
hearing and really translate to a lot of
the work that you do and if we look at
your beginnings there really wasn't an
established path to become what you
wanted to become or at least I would
imagine that there were resources but
very scattered and certainly scattered
resources also exists today but things
have have changed quite a lot and things
are developing very quickly for people
who are listening and this has been a
challenge for me to decipher as well
because I have many in my audience many
friends who come to me and ask the
question of how to become a psychedelic
therapist and I don't have a really
straightforward answer for them and I
know it's it's a sort of a process that
is is evolving but as it stands right
now if someone listening is interested
in becoming a psycho a just kind of a
psychotherapist a psychedelic therapist
of some type how would you suggest they
think about it and I suppose there are
at least two buckets you have people who
are
starting from scratch in the sense that
they don't have any of the credentials
or academic qualifications that might
help and then you have the folks who
maybe are already on second base and
just have to kind of round the corner
but if someone were starting from
scratch because we're looking forward
we're recording this in late 2000
nineteen hopefully in the next few years
at least
MDMA hopefully also psilocybin will have
completed successful phase 3 trials and
been reclassified meaning the legal
status will have changed to enable some
degree of prescription for people who
want to start preparing for that where
do they start what do they need to know
I think the first part is do your work
do your own work really understand who
you are how your experiences have shaped
you how comfortable you feel with your
own suffering I when I do trainings I
tell people the only way to not be
afraid of someone suffering is if you're
not afraid of your own and to do that we
have to know and have done our own work
so I would say that that would be a
really important one because psychedelic
work is not easy and we do experience a
lot of trauma in the room that comes out
in various ways and also to pay
attention to therapies or modalities
that honor the person as the expert of
who they are because no matter what you
know you can be poor and you can be
uneducated you're still the expert of
your experiences and who you are so no
matter who you are and and I say that
just because so many people take away
that those rights of people who are
marginalized
so to really be able to to study and be
around and read about honoring the human
being as they know more about their
healing than anybody does and can we
respect that and approach that one of
the principles for our training is that
we believe in their capacity for self
direction and for their own development
and that we also believe that they have
a healing intelligence that will show up
and that we can work with that and we
can honor that so it's not like this
hierarchical model is more like can we
meet somebody at this level together and
collaborate and create trust and and
empower them to be able to understand
and to know where their path is and to
to really respect that path and to feel
that our our own experience of ourselves
that there's room our reality makes room
for the reality of another human being
that there is room to accept that
reality so I would say that you can
start there so there's some therapies
that are good you know humanistic
therapies and client-centered therapies
that you could study but also that
there's a lot of work that you can do on
your own so it seems like we could
almost separate the preparation and
development into skill set on one hand
which is sometimes then overlapping with
qualifications it to be a legal
psychedelic therapist so let's talk more
about the skill set for a bit because I
think that's what we're talking about
there are certain modalities and I had
the the good fortune to sit through some
trainings through maps I even though I
am effectively auditing I'm not
currently preparing to be a a
psychotherapist but I really wanted to
get a better understanding
of the training that exists because one
of the big questions for me is how do we
ensure a an acceptable level of quality
as the number of therapists is scaled
through different training approaches
and it's time-sensitive right so I sat
in and in the training and just to
underscore a few things that you said
the protocol seems to really take as a
base assumption that there's a lot of
self directed healing that there's some
type of inner healing intelligence and I
remember sitting in the training and in
this case it was with a Michael and a
knee mid Hoffer and Michael said it's
always challenging to do these trainings
because we're showing you video clips of
the interventions or when we interact
but the vast majority of the time we are
doing nothing we're present paying
attention but the the patient is doing
their work and IRA but I took a lot of
notes in the process of sitting through
multiple days of of learning and I
remember one thing that stuck out which
was from the founder of ifs and I always
mispronounce is it internal family
systems and I can't remember the
gentleman's name but there's this abacus
right what was this and it's a it seems
to be a really valuable framework for
some therapists and people can look into
this on their own but he has yet an
acronym wait for therapists to remember
and it stands for why am i talking yeah
which I thought was just genius and are
there any other modalities that you
think are particularly helpful and
translate well into the mdma-assisted
psychotherapy of course not just the
session there's the pre and the post but
for instance would is how come--as is
one that comes up when allah could you
could you describe that and if and your
thoughts
and I'm not her call me therapist but I
think homie what I have seen people who
have studied her Comey they are
following they are tracking what is it
that is coming from the participant what
is it that they are meeting and how do I
trust them to really give me the
information to be able to support them
so I think a Comey is one of them
internal family systems is too mostly
because in you know I see it every
single time that in especially in MDMA
sessions that parts come out and it
happens really naturally and I think you
know we all have parts and people always
say like oh like you know where does
that come from but we all have parts you
know people always say like oh a part of
me wants to go to that party and a part
of me doesn't want to go that's a part
and not necessarily that you need to
study internal family systems but have
knowledge of multiplicity of parts show
up the inner healer is a part and when
do they show up and how do we how are we
really present with that maybe the part
that shows up is five years old and if
it's five years old we don't want to
talk to them like they're 40 you know we
want to be able to be be sensitive to
the fact that this is a five-year-old
part what do I need to do to connect to
this part so I think parts work is
really important
familiarity with non-ordinary States you
know I it's hard for me to think of
being able to do this work without
having had some experience yourself of a
non-ordinary state to really it's
because it's hard to explain right it's
hard to explain what it's what it does
very difficult to explain are there are
there certain tools that you've found
helpful of course we could talk about
the things that are gray or gray area or
not so a gray area in terms of molecules
that can help with this
and just for people who are wondering on
spelling hikami sha kom i if you want to
look it up
are there any tools that you have found
particularly helpful whether that's
holotropic breathwork or other
breathwork
or other legal means to induce
non-ordinary states of consciousness for
people who recognize and agree that it
would be important to have the first
person experience yeah but before
presuming to know how to handle someone
else and going through that experience
yeah well I wanted to say a couple of
things about that so we we do have a
study currently called Mt 1 which Rick
mentioned briefly this morning was that
this morning yes he said he talked a
little bit about Mt one so empty one is
is a study designed to for the therapist
themselves to have the experience of
MDMA so they it's a five day process
they come for a preparatory session then
they have a treatment session
integrative session and a treatment
session an integrative session and one
of those two treatment sessions is a
placebo and the other one is for MDMA
and so the therapist get the experience
not only you know some of them have had
and they may before and in in a
different context
sometimes even recreationally and this
but this feels their friend because it's
exactly the setting that they're gonna
be in there's two therapists there's
music the goes on that the whole day
there's times for them to go inside and
times for them to connect and and relate
and so it's if so many of them have said
this has this has really solidified my
training now I really do feel ready to
go and do it so that's great and we have
it the the other part of that mt2 which
is what we want to continue when we do
trainings with people to give them and
that's and it's in the fda right now
it's like negotiations with the fda for
that study so i think that is great and
I hope we can
you know we are able to continue that
work but holotropic breathwork is one
way to really get into a non ordinary
state it's um in a way that is legal
ketamine is another way you know like it
ketamine work does create that I think
meditation does that sometimes certain
yoga does that as well so it's like
really being able to say what is it what
does this actually feel like when my ego
is not the most important part when I
when I'm starting to connect to kind of
like it
I studied transpersonal so is this idea
of that we are in relationship to
our-our non-ordinary states that it is
beyond the ego and how can we go there
so to have that experience I think it's
really really important and participants
are asked you know if they always I say
have you done this you know and they
there's just a sense of calm for them
when you say yes I have what are the as
things stand right now
legal checkbox or qualification checkbox
checkbox is needed if one wants to be a
psychedelic therapist a few years from
now or five years from now and I don't
know the answer to be perfectly honest
as part of there is no so excited about
having this conversation is that to
satisfy the demand safely and adeptly of
that the reclassification of some of
these compounds will bring there needs
to be a quite a large funnel of people
who are interested in understanding at
least what the roadmap might might look
like and what we'll talk about other may
be a reality is that people should be
aware of before they sign up we'll get
to that but first what does the training
process look like is there an
educational requirement do you have to
have gone to college are there things
you can do in two years what what does
the path look like so some of that is in
the negotiation right now at the FTA in
terms of
are who are therapy pairs can be you
know one thought is that any one of them
needs to be a PhD which I'm totally
opposed to because I don't have a PhD
and so then I still want to be able to
do this work and and I think it's really
based on psychotherapy experience not
necessarily if you're a PhD and MD or
not
so hopefully that won't be the case
right now we have a one clinician is
licensed and the other one doesn't have
to be licensed but they still need to
have done at least three years of work
in a mental health profession so it
could be a nurse it could be an MD it
could be a psychiatrist it could be a
chaplain there was there was some some
question about chaplaincy early on and
that could be another one and then
psychotherapists and different
clinicians but they don't have to be
nice uns
and so they just for clarity what type
of license are we talking about so like
having a license to be a psychotherapist
to to be able to say that you're a
psychotherapist in different states have
different requirements for that so so
that's what we've done and what we hope
to continue doing to do their own work
to have experience with working with
trauma with adults it's it's a really
important one and then also if they're
affiliated with an existing site then
there's more probability because the
sites when people apply they apply as a
site so there's at least two therapists
or two clinicians who are going to sell
and they you do need to have an MD to
hold a Schedule one license and then a
facility right a facility where you can
actually do this safely set in setting
is so important right so a place that
really feels comfortable that where they
can be and everybody can feel safe and
the participants can feel safe so um
so those are some of the requirements
that we have we've trained about 500
therapists so far and about 150 of them
have gone through the whole certificate
program our program is a five-part so
the first part Part A is online is an
online course and then Part B is one
week in in-person course which is the
one that you did right I did the online
as well so I did the part 1 and part 2
okay great and so a lot of people have
done those you know like the people that
have trained have done those two parts
and then a Part C is when they do they
either have they do a training that they
think would be really valuable to do
this work somatic is something that I
didn't mention somatic work is really
important because trauma is definitely
held in the body and MDMA is very
somatic so sometimes people do those
kinds of trainings and that fulfills
that Part C and another the way that we
want to do it is through this M t1 or MT
to that where the therapists can come
and take MDMA and a safe place and the
same way they're gonna do it and so
where they maybe consider another person
doing it as well with one of us and then
so you get this really nice experience
right that is right hands-on and then
the next part is within their sites they
do role plays that are then that they
can then let us know and they have to
write about them and we we get we give
them supervision based on what happened
in the world place and the role plays
are based on real-life experiences and
questions come up and things you know
like oh I I didn't know how to do this
or they just get more and more help
because they're doing this kind of role
play role playing and then we would also
supervise their first participant at
their work
so one of our supervisors would be
watching their videos and like really
extensively as part of our training
we've done that where we looked at their
videos and given them feedback and you
know we're talking about like eight-hour
session videos so so for people who are
listening who do not have academic or
medical credentials currently but they
want to explore the first few steps of
putting themselves into a position where
they can perhaps sit in the room with
someone else who is licensed if you want
to become a licensed psychotherapist you
can figure that out on your own but
let's assume that that is not in the
cards for people who are listening but
they want to be that second person or
put themselves in a position where the
odds are increased that they'll be able
to do that what what are some first
steps that you might suggest to them
aside from the experiential the
first-hand experiences but the actual
prerequisites for moving in that
direction I'm not sure I I hope I
understand your question correctly but
in order for them to get to that place
of being able to really sit then they
need to have had these things that I've
mentioned you know they need to have
some experience working with trauma and
that they're working towards either
licensure or that they're in the process
they're registered or you know that
they're in the process of it and if just
we made it specific that was a terribly
worded question that I gave you had a
very long one I was like a paragraph you
can ask in Spanish brain vomit up what
if I or any way I could I could I think
it would be even four but we'll see
we'll see how well my caffeine kicks in
so porteño trucho the deagle aware that
intensive we should do in english so
the now my brand's running off on this
completely other tangent but I'll try to
I'll try to reel in the Marlin here for
a second back Tim thread Maps training
yes so if someone were listening they're
sitting in Chicago and if they have an
undergrad degree but no advanced degree
would you suggest they go to the Maps
website first to gain the experience
that you're talking about what are some
of the less intimidating experiences
that people could test for a week or two
or three are there any particular
suggestions that you might have I see
what you're saying
you know they we don't have any of the
scheduled trainings for next year yet
but we will by the end of this year so I
would suggest a now and I'll put some at
the end at the end of the session I'll
have the website the websites up to
apply for the newsletter and then to to
get information and to keep getting
updates about when the trainings are and
what is required and what are the
changes that have happened but there's
also a space where there's other people
from different parts of the country and
the world that really want to get a site
together or are really interested in
this world too and so we've had people
that even though we don't know when it's
going to get approved we don't know
those those things yet people still want
the training and they want to connect
with each other so they get together and
they I've heard people like meeting once
a month and then they go through the
protocol and they go through the
treatment manual and they start talking
with each other and saying like what
would it take for me to do this and feel
comfortable like I'm gonna do
preliminary work until I can get into a
training or until it becomes you know
something I can do in the future so
there's a lot of things to do in the
meantime in community in connection with
other people who are wanting the same
thing and since we have those things
online you know we have
protocols online we have our treatment
manual online and so they can do a lot
of work to begin with yeah you can
effectively may simulate the first part
of the training by become of course
there are gonna be major gaps but by
becoming very familiar with the
treatment manual and so on master work
everybody here probably knows that URL
but people listen am I not the
conversation brings up some memories
that I have of gathering some first-hand
experience of my own by volunteering
with zendo and I bring this up because
Liana who's part of the team here at
maps had mentioned to me that perhaps
one question people should ask
themselves before asking do I want to be
a psychedelic therapist is do I want to
be a therapist and that psychedelics
have this very sexy Sheen warm its puts
a very nice paint job on that Corvette
of a therapy job that you might not have
taken otherwise but volunteering at
zendo and for people who don't know is
and I know the the tagline has changed
so forgive me if I screw this up but
it's pure based harm reduction and in
effect and what that means is people go
through trainings at a place where it is
likely that some attendees to say a
festival or Burning Man will have what
they would consider a bad trip and
you're then trained to hold space and
sit with that person and I recommend
this to anyone in part because it
highlights just how unsexy it can be if
that makes sense right because people
think like yeah I'm gonna sit there and
I'm gonna walk them through their trauma
and like heal their soul and like it's
be gone I'm gonna be this awesome shop
and it's gonna be great
and then you're like no actually there's
vomiting on your pants and you need to
go get some napkins because they snot it
all over your like back your hand and
then they're asleep and you're just
sitting there for six hours cuz they're
asleep like yeah that's also the job
and I remember sitting there at zendo is
kind of hilarious I was sitting there I
did a lot of shifts I'd basically the
only reason I went to these festivals
was to do as many shifts as possible
someone like me
and I remember this guy next to me had
he pulled out his like contraband
laminated page that he had with all his
like secret techniques that he was going
to use in his session like completely
outside of the protocol and then his
person was just like I don't wanna
listen to your words and like when this
guy was like my art my art doesn't bode
very well for this guy so what are some
other maybe just realities that people
should be aware of if they think they
want to commit to doing this I'm so glad
you mentioned sendou because I've from
so many people I've heard people that
we've trained I've heard this is where I
got my best training because it's in
this in the moment and you need to be
present for that you don't know what
they took so it's even you know it the
safety piece it's not the same as if you
know like this is MDMA you took it an
hour a half ago in this setting you know
so it really amps that up and so I think
it's the best training because then
you're you're not rolling right like
you're training with somebody right
there live and you're doing that work so
sometimes people do get like wow this is
really hard work and I always tell
people if they get the message when they
take a psychedelic that they should be a
shaman it's a lie
yeah and protip if if you meet anyone
who's running around calling themselves
a shaman probably also a fair indicator
that they're not anything near paying a
shaman that's a whole separate diatribe
so yeah don't find your shamans on
Craigslist or Facebook recommendation
number one I I think one of the also
valuable things that I took from not
just send oh but watching for instance a
documentary called trip of compassion
which I recommend to everyone everyone
consider
becoming a psychedelic therapist or
psychotherapist utilizing MDMA as in as
an assisting molecule should watch trip
of the compassion because it makes the
case at least for me very strongly with
lots of session footage that if you're
not willing to sit for someone with what
we might consider the classic
psychedelics LSD psilocybin etc of
course I'm not recommending doing
anything in a legal setting but if
you're not willing to do that you
probably shouldn't sit
you shouldn't guide at a high level or
facilitate an MDMA session in the sense
that they can be very very very
difficult like you're experienced
recreationally we're all this trauma was
unlocked and to be good in that setting
really requires proper training and a
high degree of sensitivity and it can be
really hard I mean you can have someone
who let's say was abused by their father
and suddenly they project that on to you
as the male and the dyad and you need to
have hopefully some type of training or
experience that enables you to handle
that in a way that doesn't create more
damage yeah yeah I I think you know I've
I've heard it many times when people say
like oh I want to become MDMA therapist
and I worry about people practicing
outside their their competency because
they think oh the medicine will carry it
will carry the session and I've seen the
harm caused by that many times I've had
a lot of referrals into my own private
practice where people had a really
traumatic experience on a psychedelic
because their sitter somebody who was
sitting for them could not hold that
space and it just created more harm and
so to really be aware of that that being
in a non ordinary state being a
vulnerable state you won you
you're gonna pick up on that and want to
know that you're with people that can
hold that and that can and it can be
there for you and I think that that
movie is so great that we have that
expect that we have that access to to
show what people can do yeah yeah also
showcases some very gifted therapists
yes some very gifted youth all and Karen
and other people very very gifted
therapists and it shows you how how
tough it can be in a way I would even
argue that say in my zendo experience
this guy can't came in fortunately in
this one case we knew what he'd taken
which was 400 micrograms of LSD for
those who don't know is a healthy dose
or maybe using different adjectives it's
a dose capital D and he was losing his
mind swinging at people so I ended up
with him in the crisis tent for eight
hours and it was fine and it was
actually in a way I think easier
flailing and swinging and trying to hit
you aside then MDMA because he was just
on like a 45 second loop talking about
Seinfeld and like Chia Pets who's like
Seinfeld jib at problem level and then
it was just like repeat every whatever
47 seconds and you're like all right
this guy's just on rerun fine like sit
him down don't let him run into anything
but with the MDMA experience there there
really is a tradecraft that is is I
don't think I'll I'll do justice by
trying to emphasize how technical it can
be which is one piece of the puzzle and
then there's that sensitivity that you
talked about and that awareness that
really comes from probably some degree
of hardwiring but then spending time in
that environment and if if the patient
senses that you are uneasy which they
will then it changes the entire dynamic
what are what are other things besides
people practicing outside of their
competency right so if bunny slope
skiers who are like I can do a black
diamond besides those people
what other things concern you what are
their worries do you have looking
forward as things continue to become
more popular and more people hope to
become involved in some capacity yeah I
think you know changing our model is our
model it doesn't necessarily mean that
it's like the best model right and
people do mean the maps of all right the
Maps model and people might do something
else and it might be fine you know I
think one thing that concerns me is the
cost so we're really looking into that
and thinking about what is this gonna be
that we can actually that this can be
cost-effective how are we going to treat
marginalized people how are we going to
not leave people behind what is it gonna
take you know and and so I think there
is room to change the model for that and
how do we do it safely do we have some
group sessions do we have some where
it's practitioners who are mmm training
but they are like students and so maybe
they don't cost as much if they're
working under somebody who is trained
and has more experience and what are
some of the things that can be done
without losing the integrity of the
whole program and so I think you know
that is a concern but it's also a
concern if if somebody takes that and
changes it completely in a way that
maybe it's not safe anymore you know so
there's a concern about what what can
happen there but for us I think the
concern about how are we going to make
this affordable and how are we going to
continue training people that want to be
ready and want one1 that kind of
knowledge in terms of like hands-on our
training shows a lot of videos that are
lie
videos of what happens in sessions and
sometimes it's very exciting and like
you said you know that Michael was
saying we're showing this parts where
we're actually doing something there's
times when people don't say anything for
eight hours for the entire session yeah
and nonetheless just this is so
important nonetheless if you look at say
I suppose the Cape's 5 is the current
yes rankings the assessment tool for
symptoms of PTSD nonetheless you have
somebody who goes from extreme symptoms
unable to hold a job
this isn't every person but two
asymptomatic even though there was no
talking there is no right there's no
sort of you know Raphael Michelangelo
level like therapy magic happening there
was a therapeutic effect in the session
with the container with the prep yeah
and didn't require talking in the same
yeah I think insights when people go
inside and really are not they're both
really important a lot of trauma caused
by another person happened in
relationship right there was we we
relate to the world through relationship
is the way we understand the world so
healing also happens in relationship and
happens through relating instead of an
isolation so those pieces are really
important and it's also really important
when they can go inside our our model we
say it's inner directed it's what comes
up for them that is here for a reason
and for the purpose of healing and maybe
it's something that they never told you
before and you think it doesn't have
anything to do with their trauma or they
think it doesn't have anything to do
with the trauma but it does and so we
treat it as though it does and that it
is important for them to be with it and
if they're inside they get these amazing
insights you know they come out and say
wow like I just realized this where I
just thought about this and
we noticed that when they go to the
bathroom and we call it the bathroom
inside but it's really when they're not
talking it's like the shower is the
bathroom in the mirror but they're also
like with themselves you know they're
not talking and and they're getting
powerful information that is about them
that is like here we are like maybe we
knew this but now it's becoming clearer
when you look back at your first ex
number I don't know what number to pick
but first few dozen experiences as a
facilitator as a therapist
what were your hardest sessions for you
and why what made them difficult if you
think back to let's say the first few
years of your experience one of the very
first sessions that I did was in the
study in Spain and that study was
working with women from sexual assault
so it was very close to mine my
experience so I was like how do I work
with this how do i how am i present how
am i how do i not bring my things in how
do i not dissociate how do I really
honor that I am here for this person and
my stuff is not spilling out into them
so that was a challenge you know and and
I think hearing their stories was so
amazing it's so like when people are in
pain and our suffering they're so real
there's nothing you know they're not
thinking about whether hair looks like
they're not they're not worried if snots
coming out of their nose and they're
just so incredibly real in that moment
and in that and in that experience so
it's beautiful in that sense and it's
also like so painful you know to hold
the experiences of people that have
suffered greatly and to really be able
to to say I am here completely for you
this is your day and it's about you
what does good preparation look like for
a session like this or a session in the
Maps protocol we could certainly talk
about it within that context but in your
mind what are the the hallmarks of the
characteristics of good preparation for
someone who has never used MDMA before
who's going into their first
mdma-assisted psychotherapy session as a
patient
what is how do you work with them to
prepare well okay what do we do to
prepare them yeah that's what I should
have asked yep so so we do three
preparatory sessions and during those
sessions is two for them to get to be
more comfortable with the therapy team
and for them for us to also know like
how do they how did they cope with their
experience one of the things that they
have been able to work at them here in
relationship to the fact that they have
all this drama how is it that they
actually got here and what are their
skills what are they using so to be
really curious about them their skills
like coping mechanisms or coping
mechanisms what are their stigmas that
follow them that then creates this place
of I see them as a certain person
because they have this stigma attached
to them and how do I take that away and
really see this person in front of me
what is their vision even if they don't
know what it is what do I imagine that
their vision is so it's a really a time
to get to know them fully as an
individual as a person and then to
answer their questions and to try to
bring as much comfort as possible to
explain everything that can be explained
this is where you're going to lay down
you can bring a pillow you can bring
your own stuff you know we're gonna is
it okay if we light a candle we're gonna
have flowers this is what we can do
these are the options we listen to music
you can say you don't want to hear the
music it's it's up to you these are the
things that you don't have a choice
about people with PTSD
we're not giving choices choices were
taken away so it's really important to
give choice as much as we possibly can
and there's some things that we don't
have a choice about because this is
research and so one of them is once they
take it they can't leave the room for
eight hours and how are we going to work
with that if you do want to leave the
room because it's not about you hiding
that but it's about us working with that
how can we work together if you feel
like you just want to run away or if you
want to go outside and hug that tree and
unfortunately we can't let you go
outside and hug that tree just imagining
that and the summary table at the end of
the researcher for like number of trees
hugged on average three and a half
standard deviation right makes makes it
more complicated no I kept thinking like
with a little chainsaw and cut part of
the tree and bring it in but that's one
solution so what would be an example of
what you might say to someone who goes I
can't do this I got to get out of here I
really need to be outside do you first
remind them of the commitment that they
made earlier and the rule they agreed to
how do you handle a situation like that
where someone just wants to escape
they're like I don't like this I'm ready
for this to be over and go outside how
do you really remind them of the
commitment I mean at some point maybe
you do need to say well you know we're
not gonna be able to leave but we're
really here with you in this process of
you feeling what you're feeling your
legs wanting to move and wanting to run
and where you know can I hold your hand
can I sit beside you can we stay with
this experience it will pass this
experience will pass what can we do in
the meantime what are some of their
coping strategies if they really get to
a place where they feel like oh I need
to breathe can we breathe into that
experience and just really be with it
and know that it is going to shift
they're worried we're right here with
you so it's about it's totally okay and
it usually leads to
a profound experience of wanting to have
run away before right it's like a
connection to this piece of it was then
that I wanted to run away not so much
now I'm gonna keep teasing on this
thread because you're so good at this
and the specifics I think really helped
to paint a picture of what a session
might look like what do you do if
someone or what might you do or say if
someone gets very judgmental about
themselves like oh I [ __ ] hate when I
die god this is so stupid I always [ __ ]
about and then becomes very judgmental
about themselves as a whole or apart I
hate that part of myself who's da da da
something they've really really shut
down and judged what might you say to
someone who's going through a period of
expressing no one part of our model and
the way that we train is to say it's not
never to get rid of anything it's like
alchemy you don't you don't get rid of
it you transmute it right that it gets
transmitted and so it's not about
getting rid of anything at all even that
part of you that is judgmental so it's
not like mmm
at least like I wouldn't say no but you
know you don't have to judge yourself or
anything it's just like this is the part
that is here now this judgemental part
and being really curious about that part
and why is there like wow like this part
is existing here right now how has it
helped you survive how have you worked
around it let's explore why it's here
and what it's bringing up in your body
and what it's making you feel in this
very moment this is why you're so much
better at this so good you've done so
much good work it's really it's a big
deal it's a really big deal and it's so
thrilled to have you on stage to have a
chance to talk about this what separates
in your mind if you look back at all the
people you've worked with a good
psychedelic therapists let's focus on
MDMA specifically
versus a great psychotherapist like the
good people versus the great because I
feel like you can check a bunch of boxes
and kind of get a passing grade get
somebody out the door safely and then
there's then there's really good and
then there's a great therapist and and
I'm not sure I would even necessarily
know how to describe what separates us
to be because I don't have the canvas
that you have meaning of such a you've
such a perspective on this so if you
think back on your experiences with
different people there any any examples
you could give of what makes someone in
your mind great or stories that come to
mind anything well I think the most we
can offer is ourselves so I think it's
when we can enter I think what makes a
psychedelic therapist grade is if we can
enter into their frame of reference and
in order to enter into somebody's frame
of reference I have to leave my
interpretations behind I have to leave
my own story behind I have to leave my
own knowledge behind I have it right
there and I understand that I can use it
but not letting my knowledge blur my
vision not not for it not to narrow what
is really happening here so in order to
really step into somebody's experience
it's more than empathy it's empathy is
is part of it but it's really about I am
not at all I have like like this
disciplined ignorance of I'm stepping in
and I'm fully here with you without any
judgment and who are you in there and
how do I begin to know that I can hold
that and that it doesn't mean oh I know
how you feel because I felt that it's
not that I can have my own feelings I
think I know what this feels like
because I've had it
but it has nothing to do whether fit
with what they're feeling and to put
that aside and to know that that's my
stuff
and so I think in part is that and the
other piece is that which maybe relates
to that is if I don't spill over any of
my stuff
like they they see me and I they get me
but they don't have to take care of me
and I can even cry and say I'm so moved
by this and it's okay so I had like we
had a participant that said to me he was
a little bit worried that some of his
the things that he would share would be
too much for me and he said so are you
going to I what are you gonna do what
are you gonna feel like what are you
gonna think of me if I tell you these
really awful things that happened and
more and if I tell you these things
about myself like what are you gonna do
like are you going to be okay like are
you gonna be able to just be okay and
not be faced by that and I thought I
might have a really strong feeling about
that it might be really challenging and
really hard and I can take care of
myself
it's okay I can take care of myself but
it might be really really hard we're
gonna talk about post as well because I
don't want to neglect that but to dig a
little bit deeper on the e not making
the session about you right having all
these narratives about your own
experience spill over is there a place
for sharing pieces of your own
experience in a showing of vulnerability
in the preparation or is it just like I
am a doctor authority figure and you
know need-to-know basis as far as
background like is is there a value in
the perpetrator sessions of sharing what
has brought you there
in addition to hearing what brought them
there is there a value in that or does
that contaminate the process in some
fashion in our face to study every time
a participant came in you know we didn't
have a lot of media at the time there
wasn't a lot of stories that have been
written about MDMA maps was not
necessarily known by a lot of people
including some of the participants they
had never even heard of maps they were
just referred by somebody else and they
would come into the room and they would
go away your Marcella like they were
expecting me to be wearing like a white
lab coat and and it was like it was
really like interesting you know what
they were expecting and I think
self-disclosure is very valuable and it
also needs to be done with a lot of care
so that it doesn't become about you and
when do you self disclose and why are
you self disclosing you know are you
doing it in service of you because
you're uncomfortable and you need to do
something with this or am i doing it in
service of my participant to normalize
something and to share with them an
experience that I'm having and so I I'm
definitely not this kind of therapist I
think I don't know which is better but
I'm just not it and I do self disclose a
lot like my clients know you know that
I'm married my kids my co therapist is
my husband and I we talk about it
sometimes and we say you know we're
married and things come up in the
session sometimes like oh I disagree
with you and we talk we talk through it
and they go like this is so great that
we're getting this experience of this
reality you mean you and your you and
your husband disagree in the session
yeah all right how do you what what are
the rules of engagement for that well
I'm still his boss like you know what no
elbows so I'm guessing got a box clean
boxing yeah how do you what would be an
example of something you might disagree
on this is really interesting to me so
on so many levels this is like levels
upon levels of interesting I don't
remember the specifics but one time
I said something to the participant I'm
trying to think what it was do you
remember no and I was going in a
direction like I I didn't think I was
going in a direction but I was even
though like that's what you would I
checked myself with it's like I might
what am I going in this direction like
are they taking me in this direction and
I thought the participant was taking me
in this direction and he thought the
participant was taking us in a different
direction and he was able to say well I
see this a little bit differently I'm
seeing this differently and actually the
participant went like what and and then
we had a conversation about it and he
said his piece and I said well I don't I
don't know like I don't know about that
I wasn't convinced and we worked with it
and we worked with her it wasn't like we
just got stuck on it but later on she
was having an interview somebody was
interviewing her and she talked about it
and she said that was so great because
it was like seeing these two people who
clearly love each other and respect each
other
disagree and be okay and continue and
still support each other and respect
each other is something that I never saw
growing up so it's like so valuable for
her if it was done in this way that was
that was genuine yeah I can definitely
see that what does the post look like
and if if we just to tag to put some
hours on it the three preparatory
sessions are how long each 90 minutes 90
minutes all right so we got 90 90 and
then how many posts or integration
sessions are there three also 90 minutes
each okay so someone else can add that
all up but I just want to say one thing
which is if you are not willing to put
that type of prep and post into anyone
you sit for you shouldn't be sitting for
anyone if it's like oh that's so much
time what's busy at a look at mine if
this is a school night but well if you
have any excuses around it you shouldn't
be sitting for anybody
that's just my perspective that's true
because that's that's that's a hurdle
that I think you should at least be able
to clear yeah before even considering
this and that's putting aside all of the
homework and training and certification
and so on and you're still on call like
that night the evening of their sessions
you're on call they're still gonna you
still make phone calls after their
session for seven days you they can call
you and say I need an extra session or
I'm struggling and you need to be
present and go there so it's a lot more
than just the the scheduled one
sometimes right that's the scheduled
time yeah and I think it's worth
pointing out also that if you are
knowingly or unknowingly and it could be
unknowingly working with someone who has
a history of trauma and possibly
suicidal ideation you could end up in
some very challenging situations and it
is not always the case
that people have say an mdma-assisted
psychotherapy session and then it's just
smooth sailing for the next week it's
not right so could you talk to that
because I think it's this is a an aspect
of the experience that is is not
discussed as often as it should
yeah and and I do think you know I
really appreciate stories that are that
go out that the media does about MDMA
and one of the services is that a lot of
times they hook on these little words I
get healed me or it was you know I I got
what I needed and I got cured and so so
then people think like it's really easy
or that MDMA is like this magic pill
that's gonna like really take this drama
away which is not true and and a lot of
times during training trainees will say
wow like here's the integrative session
after the treatment and
and people are suffering and people are
really struggling and they can feel a
lot of activation and they can even feel
like even like sometimes their partners
say to us what are you doing to my
partner you know what are you doing she
is in so much pain he's in so much pain
and and it's if you think about trauma
like no matter how much you heal from
trauma if I think about my trauma is
gonna be painful
it's not gonna be joyous and easy it's
gonna be painful so bringing up the
trauma really experiencing sometimes
even getting I think part of the healing
that happens with MDMA is people no
longer questioning that it happened and
that it happened as violently as it did
and that they have sort of tried to
question that try to change the story
and all of a sudden the story can be
changed here's your story you know
that's what happened to me that first
time here's your story actually so so
then how could you possibly like if
you're going through all that it's it's
not going to be that the next day you're
oh I'm fine and it's great it's that it
is a process of holding of really
integrating what is happening the
session of getting to someplace where
they can begin to hold that experience
and be able to hold their feelings and
be able to I mean healing is about I'm
never it's not about I'm never going to
be triggered healing is I can get
triggered and I can move through it and
maybe it's going to take me less time
and maybe I'm not going to dissociate
and I can hold all of that experience
and still having our space to live a
beautiful life yeah
[Music]
where can people learn more about the
resources that are available the options
that are available for exploring this
work not necessarily deciding ahead of
time that this is what they should do or
will do but to to better educate
themselves to understand what's involved
to learn more yeah you know Maps has a
good library I like reading a lot of the
books there but also there's some great
articles that have been written that you
can look through that you can see
people's experiences have people have
done beautiful work talking about their
own experience and have really shared
with others about their process I know a
lot of our participants have done that
and you know it's such an honor for them
to share of themselves and this really
really want from this vulnerable places
so I would say really read read about
experiences that people have had read
about researchers writing about it
educate yourself as much as you possibly
can about the the treatment that you
want to do about being a psychedelic
therapist and even though you know we
don't have that now I know CI is the
californian Institute has a has a
certificate program for research in
psychedelics now and I'm sure that
that's going to grow and I get a lot of
emails of people asking me what do I do
where I go and I explore it a little bit
with them like what interests them maybe
I think transpersonal psychology is a
great way into it but I also say take a
lot of read articles find out where the
people who wrote those articles are from
if you really like those articles if you
feel like oh it's like-minded people
where are they are they some of them are
professors at universities where oh I
can go and study with them instead of
just going to Anna University where
nobody is
knowing about it but yet you want to be
a psychedelic therapist so where there's
other people who are already you don't
have to invent it you're not alone
there's plenty and there's a lot of
support to learn and to really you know
there's a new generation coming on and I
feel like they're a little bit in a
hurry and I keep reminding me them like
I've done this for 35 years I've waited
35 years you can wait it's okay you can
wait one more year and it's inseam
incident transpersonal psychology I'll
just quote Stan Grof whose advice at one
point people are like what should we do
next what should we do next this is
recently and egos don't [ __ ] it up yes
it's it's it's fine to move with purpose
it's generally not a good idea and
certainly not a good idea with these
compounds to rush no it's not good that
the movies not gonna it's it's not gonna
end as a romantic comedy we're gonna end
really poorly if people rush yeah and
maps people can find at maps org course
is it up there
maybe maybe Bryce can put it up yeah
we'll also for those people who are
listening to this in audio put all of
the links and many additional resources
on the website blog forward slash
podcasts if you could have teamed up log
horses podcast search Marcella ma are
CLA probably easier than the last name
then it will pop right up and and I will
gather resources that can act as
starting points that's on the maps
website links to studies for those who
want to become more familiar with study
design some of the results the tools
that are used for measurement and so on
there are a lot of very easy ways to get
started yeah org four slash training and
even though we don't have the training
set up yet for next year you can still
apply
we'll consider those applications we'll
keep them on file and we consider those
applications and like I said by the end
of this year we'll have the list for
next year and with where there will be
and our trainings are roughly around 54
54 55 trainees at a time and then people
will start knowing a little bit better
and in the meantime like gather your
team you know like or we're really
looking to the Maps website and see if
there's an existing team that is wanting
more people and that you know you don't
want to have five sites in your city you
want to be able to consolidate and be
able to say let's let's work together if
we have a common ground and and what
I'll work with you and the Maps team on
afterwards is brainstorming options like
you mentioned possible chaplain a be
having experiential options where people
can do take the boat out on the harbor
and like just do a couple of circles
before they try to cross the Atlantic to
make sure that they're okay with their
sea legs and that it's actually
something that when it's unsexy and when
it's hard you still want to do it they
still want to do I like marriage I don't
yes Molly yeah I got you yeah Molly
Molly's still very attentive she's in it
with us are there any books that have
had an impact on your thinking in this
space and I'm just gonna leave it very
broad could be that a that could be art
could be love don't let on home we
talked about that book a bit earlier
which I personally found very very
interesting which one I'm not healing
journey yep
and looks at some very very interesting
compounds and not only the compounds
with the the session content including
the dead ends including challenges it's
not just the highlight reel which I
really appreciate about that book are
there any books that have really
influenced your thinking or your
trajectory
as it relates to the work I have
dyslexia so I'm really bad with names so
I don't know if I'm gonna remember but I
know um Bruce Tift he is in Boulder
Colorado and he wrote a book called
already free already free yes Bruce TIFF
TIFF and he combines Buddhism and psycho
and psychotherapy and its really a
wonderful combination of being able to
to marry these two of being present you
know how are we present with what's
happening in the moment so I think he I
think his book is is really really good
and I'm trying to think in terms of I
mean I think you know I noticed every
time that that we show we do trainings
or we do workshops we always put up you
know we always put a poetry that really
speaks to what we're trying to say so
like when we're time talking about the
inner healer we put up poetry about that
kind of speaks to that and I think
poetry is so important because it really
does actually talk about some of these
experiences about about doing being
inner directed about your inner healer
about your compassion about your love
about where to come from that so I think
it's it's doing the work I think Stan
graphs work is amazing and his books are
very powerful and so helpful right that
we can really refer to to some of his
modality and what he's done in his
trajectory of life I think is incredible
and so people like that I'm trying to
think do you have any favorite poets I
do
let's tell me more have you pass w pass
he said he's a favorite parlor Neruda is
a favorite i I really like isabel
allende I mean she's a writer what's her
last name
I
genndy agenda uh-huh wala yes agenda
hello uh-huh
she's um she's incredible
and she really is this you know powerful
powerful woman who can who can really
speak to honoring people's experience
and and doing it through you know I'm a
Colombian so I really do see things
through images and fantasy and and those
fantasies can are actually true like my
husband doesn't believe me but some of
those things are true even though they
sound like really fantastic they're
actually true and and so not just
reading about psychology that's I just
think that's not my path I just think
there's so many other places science I
can't remember who said it was so
helpful for me in doing research because
you know holding research and holding a
person it's a real balance this is a
research part this is the part that I
need to do that I need to treat them all
the same and this is the part that is an
individual right and it's this balance
and I was having a really hard time with
that I didn't know quite how to manage
it and I read a scientific journal that
said he said science is an organized
kind of wonder and that makes so much
sense to marry these two right so that's
a great quote and it's it's also very
helpful for people who may be on the
non-clinical path currently to to at
least understand the vocabulary of a
scientific study yeah it's really
helpful and there's a book called bad
science by Ben Goldacre which has a
number of chapters that are really
helpful for becoming scientifically
literate in an unintimidating way and a
very practical way you can use it
immediately in reading any newspaper any
article that makes any claims related to
health
and then Peter Atia MD atti a Peter T MD
is websites same Peter Tiye MD comm has
a series of articles called I believe
it's studying the studies which teaches
you how to read studies and it's an
exceptional series of articles that you
can find for free which helps you to
realize if you may have through your own
experience developed perhaps an anti
what you might call Western scientific
angle that science is not shouldn't be a
set of dogma right as you said it's sort
of an organized way to wonder and
scratch that itch yeah in a way that can
then be replicated and tested so that
you know what you know when you know it
if that makes any sense
yeah so you have a certainty of knowing
which is very challenging in this space
yeah there are so many possible
variables yeah it really really matters
that you pay attention to the details
and follow protocol but it can be
incredibly challenging when you have the
science of the art which in fact do not
need to be at odds and then you can I
mean it's important to read about
science and the research about
psychedelics but I think science about
something else I've learned so much
about science through people who have
done studies with certain animals or
certain species or plants and they've
done these studies and it's like so
fascinating to really incorporate that
and to really bring it it just brings
some freshness into it that you can say
oh that makes perfect sense I'm gonna
utilize that to understand this
psychedelic research yeah and you know
it's what's so fun about this
conversation and we're out of time so
we'll wrap up for me is is seeing them
the micro and the macro and the macro
and the micro in the sense that you're
describing how you develop the skills
that you have which was borrowing
liberally and traveling these indirect
but highly relevant paths incorporating
different techniques for different areas
and in a sense in a given session you
also have to be good at coming at things
from different angles and looking at
them from different perspectives so you
see it in both and you're incredibly
gifted and more than incredibly gifted
at what you do you're very well
practiced and deliberate with what you
do and through your own pain and
suffering I've found a way to transmute
as you said that into something really
valuable and powerful for other people
who are in pain and there are a lot of
people I think that's pretty much
everyone who is born a human and you're
putting a real positive dent in the
world so thank you very much and I
really appreciate you taking the time on
stage with me and Molly I didn't throw
up on you
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email for me and
would you enjoy getting a short email
for me every Friday if that provides a
little morsel of fun before the weekend
and five bullet Friday is a very short
email where I share the coolest things
I've found or that I've been pondering
over the week that could include
favorite new albums that I've discovered
it could include gizmos and gadgets and
all sorts of weird [ __ ] that I've
somehow dug up in the the world of the
esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out
just go to 4-hour workweek dot-com
that's 4-hour workweek calm I'll spell
out and just drop in if your email
you'll get the very next one and if you
sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by helix
sleep last year I focused on
dramatically improving a few things
surprise surprise
most notably the quality of my sleep
which seems to affect just about
everything this led me to revisit you
name my daily routine morning routine
exercise diet all the way to what I
slept on and I ended up getting all new
beds here in Austin Texas including
mattresses from helix sleepin helix has
built a sleep quiz that takes two
minutes to complete and they use the
answers to match your body type and
sleep preferences to the perfect mat
whether you're a side sleeper hot
sleeper cold sleeper you like plush you
like firm with helix there's no more
guessing or confusion just go to helix
sleep comport / Tim take their two
minutes leap quiz and they'll match you
to a mattress that will give you the
best sleep of your life that is their
problem for couples
helix communits put the mattress down
the middle providing individual support
needs and feel preferences for each side
they have a 10 year warranty and you can
test drive your mattress for a 100
nights risk-free right now in helix is
offering up to 125 dollars off of all
mattress orders check it out get up to
125 off at helix sleep calm moment / Tim
let's helix sleep calm for / Tim for 125
dollars off your mattress order take a
look
helix sleep calm /tm
this episode is brought to you by ring
rings mission is to make neighborhoods
safer you might already know about their
smart video doorbells and cameras to
protect millions of people everywhere
ring helps you stay connected to your
home from anywhere in the world very
important for me given how much I travel
and bounce around so there's a package
delivery or a surprise visitor good or
bad you'll get an alert if you have a
seat here and speak to whoever is at
your door all from your phone I've
personally used reigned for years now I
have to know about ring from day one
actually i'm dr early prototypes and
throughout so I've been a user for a
long time it catches and reports all the
regular stuff like deliveries and so on
but it's also saved my ass quite a few
times
catching weirdos and we're
so ring is key to my peace of mind and
as a listener of the compare show you
have a special offer on a ring welcome
kit available right now at rings comm /
Tim T I am the kit includes a video
doorbell and a chime Pro which are just
what you need to start building and
ringing of security around your home
today check it out go to ring comm / Tim
to take advantage of this offer today or
just to learn a little bit more check
out the details at ring.com
/ Tim this offer is for US residents
only
[Applause]